people don't understand antidepressant  withdrawal they know opiate withdrawal  and it does not feel like a normal  withdrawal it's not like a hangover or a  painkiller withdrawal it's just like  being put in a horror movie I literally  locked myself in my apartment and just  waited it out thinking I was nuts there  was intense intense mood swings rage  really really severe rage like  destructive rage [ __ ] it was like two  and a half years like that could have  been my parents lives like my dad in a  hospital actively being tortured from  the side effects my mom bringing him  food every day from medications he just  needed to be taken off of  [Music]  I'm pissed off about it  [Music]